the real stuff be the hits like when you
really making a real song oh yeah yeah
them be the hits like pound town I knew
that was a hit because it was like a
real story so I'm like they going to
like they going to relate oh yeah I
definitely I know about it yeah
everybody know about Pound Town pound is
everybody know about that and how do
people get to Pound Town exactly do they
do they I mean I know it's like sex
right but at what point does sex turn
into pound town I guess I mean if it's
good like if y'all doing the [__] like
doing the damn thing yeah it got to be
good though if you it if it's not good
you wasn't in pound town for sure oh Dam
if it was whack that was not Pound Town
yeah I think I've been on the out I've
been in the suburbs probably you know
what you mean you ain't never been to
pound town I mean I've been you know
yeah I've been there it's up to you too
well it's up to both partners for real
like if it's just like magical yeah
that's pound town oh maybe I've been
yeah I probably I probably been through
there then yeah yeah I think I got to
like the vibe got to be there for both
of y'all on both ends like she can't be
whack you can't be wack it got to be
just lit up all the way you know yeah
yeah that's pound town for sure oh yeah
you having flashback I'm just thinking
I'm trying to yeah I'm making sure I've
been there I have been yeah yeah but
yeah I think a lot of yeah I've been
there I enjoyed it and what about when
it comes to men I know you talk about
you like a real strong like a t you know
a real yeah rough and tough yeah a guy
that's really you know kind of Thug is
that okay the term to use I mean you
don't have to be a thug no I don't have
a type okay I just I like um like a
strong n a strong dude though like I
ain't got no type though like he could
be a working man but still put his foot
down or be like a standup guy you know
what I'm saying he could be any type of
man but just not a weak I don't like
weak people cuz I'm not weak like so
it's going to be hard to even deal with
me and I don't want to have somebody I
can run over you know that's not fun
it's not fun no you don't want that at
all and you don't deserve that period
you deserve a champion yeah for real
yeah look at right there uhuh she coming
up dang suddenly she's a good swimmer
the internet is I sure can't swim you
think them going make me float thing
yeah girl yeah you could work start a
job as a faery the internet and I buy a
ticket come on interet is crazy big
chest or big BL I I think I like a kind
of like a moving butt a butt that's got
some activity to it like a butt that
looks busy like it's about to run off
and do
something you're funny you had so you be
looking at booties and stuff yeah I like
looking at probably some booties I don't
really care I mean I breasts are great
I'm happy that people have breasts I
like both yeah maybe I like I mean I'm
happy that everybody I'm happy that
women have them
yeah got yeah I like yeah I like I like
all of that me too I like like a curve
curvaceous yeah it's cute yeah and I got
I got I got some cheeks on me too oh so
I you know I do what I can yeah you got
to have some buns I think you let your
girl squeeze your buns maybe if we
making like dinner or something you like
grab your
booty yeah maybe I don't know is that
too much you think no it's not I mean
it's the person you with they can touch
wherever they want to on you like yeah
if that yeah if that if this if this if
y'all getting along well nice why you
going to pull that up yeah why' youall
pull that up man who's that that's me I
know that ain't you they trying to
that's real yeah they trying to is that
your real buns yeah why they look fake
it look like you poking it out on
purpose that's just how I look girl what
is you doing on there that's how I look
so you was just standing there I guess
yeah my friend it look like you straight
going like this somebody took a p they
shouldn't have done it I'm dead you
ain't got no bird or nothing hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one